قاتلات الاحتلال الحربيه قصفت صباح اليوم
هذا المنزل في مخيم النصيرات منزل عائله
زريد هذا المنزل مكون من اربع طوابق دمرت
مربع سكني كامل في هذه
المنطقه شهود عيان من هذه المنطقه يتحدثون
بوجود عدد
من المواطنين كانوا داخل هذا المنزل
وعدد يعني من المواطنين من جيران هذا
المنزل المدمر والمربع السكني الكامل الذي
دمرته المقاتلات الحربيه هم يعني موجودين
في هذ هذا البيت ضرر كبير في هذه المنطقه
كما نتابع حتى المناطق المحاذيه والمجاوره
لهذا المنزل المقصوف والمربع السكني تم
تدميره بشكل كامل يعني في هذه المنطقه
تشاهد هنا ضرر كبير
جدا بعد قصف المقاتلات الحربيه لهذا
المنزل وهذا المربع السكني تحديدا في مخيم
واحد بالنصيرات هذا البيت والمربع الس
السكني الكامل قصف قبل قليل من قبل
المقاتلات
[موسيقى]
الحربيه هذا الدمار الكبير في هذه المنطقه
والمربع السكني الكامل تحديدا مخيم واحد
بالنصيرات قصفت المقاتلات الحربيه مربع
سكني كامل كما نشاهد ونتابع واياكم عبر
قناه
الجزيره كما تحدث بعض شهود العيان من هذه
المنطقه بان
عدد من المواطنين لازالوا في هذا المنزل
هذه المنطقه هي يعني اخليت من السكان بشكل
يعني شبه كامل بعد يعني منشورات القتها
مقاتلات الاحتلال الحربيه للمواطنين
بالخروج من هذه المنطقه يعني نحن في هذا
المكان نتجول واياكم لنتعرف عن ويتعرف
المشاهد عبر قناه الجزيره على هذا الدمار
الكبير في هذا المنزل المكون من اربع
طبقات حيث قصفت المقاتلات الحربيه مربع
سكني
[موسيقى]
كامل نتجول واياكم في مخيم واحد بالنصيرات
وسط قطاع غزه رغم القصف الشديد و يعني
التوغل
البري
ل دبابات الاحتلال في المناطق الشرقيه
لمخيم النصيرات هذه المنطقه يعني
التي قصفتها المقاتلات الحربيه كما نشاهد
واياكم
[موسيقى]
هنا هذه الحفره الكبيره
التي نجمت عن
القصف الهائل والمدمر لمنزل عائله زريد في
مخيم النصيرات تحديدا منطقه مخيم واحد
بالنصيرات قد قصفته المقاتلات الحربيه
ودمرت هذا المنزل بشكل كامل دمرت المحيط
لهذا المنزل كله طع من غاز
[موسيقى]
كمان هنا قناه الجزيره ترصد لكم هذا القصف
الكبير والدمار الهائل لمنازل
المواطنين المحاذيه وللمنزل المستهدف منزل
عائله زريد في هذه المنطقه حيث قصفته
المقاتلات الحربيه ودمرت هذا المنزل بشكل
كامل ضي الحاجه والله ما هو ضي الحاجه
يرم علينا روس نوويه و الحاجه حسبي الله
ونعم الوكيل حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل ضايل
يرمو علينا نووي بس اقسم بالله ضم علينا
نوي اطفال وصغار كلهم ماتوا استشهدوا طلع
انت الحي كله الحي كله مدمر حسبي الله
ونعم الوكيل عليكم انتم كنتوا ساات
الاستهداف اه في اللينا الع شو هذا
طلعناهم من هنا
وحملناهم اسعافات طولت حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل شو هذا الحي كله مدمع حي كله مدمر
ولا دار اختها حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل كلهم
اطفال اللي مات حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل ايش
بدنا نقول هذ الدار فيها بني ادمين تحته
فيها ثلاثه فيها موجودين ناس تحت بقوللك
الناس اللي غ طالعين مصبين بس اللي هنا
لسه ضين
عايشين ككم السمع الى المواطنين هنا في
هذه المنطقه يقولون بان لازال هناك احياء
تحت هذا القصف ولازال هناك عالقين تحت
ركام هذا المنزل
ابزلز
ز يا
احمد الان عدد من المواطنين برفقه طواقم
الانقاض يحاولون
يعني المناداه على من بداخل هذا
المنزل لعل الله ان يكتب لهم يعني الحياه
وان يسرخ احد من هؤلاء الاطفال او يعني
النساء في هذا المنزل حتى يتم انتشالهم من
تحت هذا
[موسيقى]
الركام يعني نحن نسير على هذا الركام وهذا
الدمار الهائل لهذا المربع السكني الكبير
في مخيم النصيرات وانتشال عدد من الشهداء
ولازال عدد من العالقين تحت ركام هذا
المنزل ل المنزل قصف يعني في ساعه مبكره
من صباح هذا اليوم ودمر ب بشكل
كامل سنحاول الخروج من على هذا الركام من
هذه
[موسيقى]
المنطقه